バッハ
持った
初めまして坂本です
皆さん
合成人ってどんな人だと思います
例えば
いいだーシップに明日れる人を
決断力があってもみんなが
神に頼っちゃうような人ですね
こういう人が成功する
あるいは
失敗を重ねた人です
何度も何度も失敗を重ねて
そこから経験から学びついにやっとす携行する
こういう人がいいと思います
やや結局は才能ある人はないのっ
もの寿司北分かんないですけど結局は鯉沢がある人が減災て生まれてポテンシャルが
高いたから成功するんでしょっ
今僕は成功車
0というのをいくつかあげてみたんですけどみなさんの頭の中でも成功者ってこういう
人だなって
えっ
ページがあっています
増子それぞれ成功者のイメージは
違うと思いますね
で
じゃあどれが正しいんでしょうか
僕は今みなさんがそれぞれ
を創造する成功者のイメージというのは全て正しいと思います
ですが
光精工舎のメージっていうのは色々あっていろんな成功し方っていうのはあるんです
けどみんな共通してある思っ
これ何かわかりますか
それ自身です
じゃあみんな自信を持てば
成功できるんじゃないか
みんな自信を持ってたら成功できるんでしょ
でも地震でいうのはだからかいらねもなんです
彼ら自身というのは何度も何度も成功を繰り返して
少しずつ自分のものにしてそしてそれが今今日もあるものにならないと
自身7か
もし仮に
はいちょっと自分成功者なそういう体験をしてお礼のこの自信にしてやろうとそう思っ
たら
きっとそこにはマン氏になったり
だから自信レール難しいです
僕も自信あって持っていませんだから逆転の発想です
モテないんじゃなくてモーター言うんです
だから自信がない僕がいい
自身を必要とせずに成功する方法を見つけました
それは
虫になるのです
今日は不信になることで何なのか
これを伝えします
a 僕はお薬影響で本当にちっちゃい時から参戦外部からテニスをしていました
小学校に上がってからは試合にも出るようになりました
鷲谷人間では曲げでふてくされて
言い方をすると親の愛のめち
これを受けながらなんとか中学卒業まで豪華テニスを頑張ることができましょう
でも
自分の中で満足した的かというのは
買い物後しょうがなかったんですね
そして高校受験です僕は以前から連絡したいなぁと思っていた九州にある公園神学校し
ました
どの高校っていうのは全国大会でも何度も優勝団体で優勝経験を
飾っている方向で僕がその高校に入ってへぎゅらーメンバーとして
団体全国制覇ん
これを目指してニーズに仕込んでいきましたん
a 卒業と下3年生になってからづぎならの面は竿格闘しました
として2016年3月
多くの無心のきっかけとなる全国大会に出場しました
平成線
とにかくがむしゃらに
頑張って頑張ってプレーをしてきました
そしてチームはベスト8ベスト大野全国で勝ち上がっていきましょう
僕自身こんなに全国大会で8上がった経験なんていうか
分かったので
この時僕が考えていたのはもうただ目の前の試合にいたずら集中をしよう
ただこれだけを考えていました
チームはいよいよあすっ
決勝戦というところができたんですよ
そして僕は全水の夜
明日かでは全国制覇できんじゃん夢叶う者
なんか自分の中の自信のようなもの市やべびたんですね
それに
優秀知れば
いい外膜
立教赤が映えるんじゃないので
分子だしたら
てるんじゃない
そんな余裕まで生まれちゃってよ下の考えるん
当日
僕は
すごい自分自身を持ってコートに入っていました
ん
ですが待っていたのは
まったく反対の剣でしたいっ
僕が今までにないぐらい身長してしまったです
手足が増えても何もできない
もう焦って焦ってしょうがないですね
でも原因がわからない自分や自信があるし今日絶対勝てると思ってるん
でも枦川うまくいかないです
思い通りのプレーができない
なんでなんでなんでなんでって思っているとどんどん
冷静な判断はできないんです
天川
準優勝で終わってしまいですか
ちまく
本当に
二本目につかない日々を送っていたんですけど
一つだけアドローマ彼には常にあの日の試合だけが残っていました
ん
毎日毎日学校にでも授業をおおっと聞いて
ただあの日の試合のことだけが2と後円も手です
これが前に続いて南キャン品女子たんだろっ
と考えていき等
ようやく
この原因を理解する
自信っていうのは
依存しすぎるとお菓子になる
写真は
自分に余裕を民営
それは役に立ったおります
いざというのはうわー
準備不足を招いていっ
本番を大事な画面になって焦りとして表れです
だから
簡単に手に入れた自信っていうのはを押しながらあるなっ
にをもって実感しました
ですが
逆1回戦から決勝まで勝ち上がっていた時っていうのは
邪念が一切なく
ただ
一つの目的に向かって周知をしていたっ
これが僕の理想とする物心の状態です
生まれ
無神経のは
集中力を高める
平行に皿です
それではここで僕が
心理になる方々一月
そしてそれを実践して成功したいっていうのをお話しします
えっそれはですね
ので昨年の秋の関東大学に3
大学に入ってからの援助団体その他に
出来事です
え僕はこの時全12試合に出場してー
11勝ありました
僕にとってこれは本当に成功体験でしょ
それと同時に
この成功体験までの
準備
これが重要な
感じました
まず先ほども伝えました
無心になるためには邪念を全部すべて
あったひとつの目的に向かって集中しなければいけない
でもなかなか本番緊張する場面でそれって嬉しいですよね
だから準備をするんです
椅子に置いてだったり仕事においてだったり
例えば犬スティン者ですねテスト
それぞれ工夫する準備いけば全然違うんですけど
第10緊張と焦りって言っ
これどこに置いてもあるじゃねえんだと思うんですよ
だから
胸腔していっ
この蛇命を捨てる方法
お伝えしますテニスでよくさあブーツ前にこうやって
団塊がボールを作るのいたことがありしているんです
愛選手によっ
使えそうで違うんですよね
それっていうのは自分の中でボールを何回ついたら落ち着ける
安心してプレイがヌキッ
声を決めて
毎日毎日同じことを繰り返しているは何です
これ同じことを繰り返していれば本番でも同じように落ち着いてプレーができる
ということは落ち着いてプレーが出来るから緊張や汗いっていうのは
栗原振っん
をラティスに限ったことじゃなくて日常生活というと
テスト前絶対県庁するな
だったらじゃあ日頃から毎日同じ時間にコーヒーを一杯の思う
そしてゲスト前のコーヒー用
これを決めておく
あるいは大事なプレゼンがある
その前に都合等自分の大好きな音楽を聴こう
じゃあこれを毎日絶対に繰り返し行こう
そうすることでこれはブーンピンかさえ
本番で同じようにいや音楽毎日見て今日も聞いたから
いつも橇系
こういう風になって一つずつ
チャレンジの取り払う工夫準備っていうのができているんです
僕はこういうのを一つ一つ考えてこの試合に挑んだ結果成功することができました
影響僕は無心になることについてここまで伝えてきました
大きくまとめて3つです
自身は自身に合う出身だということを
無心っていうのは邪念が一切なく
一つの目的に向かって集中していたけど
爪は
無心になるためには賃金が大切だということです
皆さん
成功の鍵は無視んです
ございました
[拍手]